it's great to welcome back to the
program Chuck Collins who is a
researcher campaigner storyteller and
writer based at the institute for policy
studies where he Co edits inequality dot
org he's written extensively on wealth
inequality in previous books the new
book is born on third base a one
percenter makes the case for tackling
inequality bringing wealth home and
committing to the common good Chuck it's
so great to have you back and so much of
the book up really refers to much of
what is the debate around Donald Trump
and his so-called credentials as a good
businessperson there are those who say
that trumps business credentials are
truly incredible what we've been able to
do really is an example of starting with
very little and growing it through his
business acumen and expertise and skills
and there are others who say when you
start on third base as you might argue
Donald Trump did you're going to score a
lot of runs and that that sort of the
the analogy as to what took place there
let's just get into it there how do you
see and interpret this idea of being
born on third base and thinking you hit
a triple in light of the Trump campaign
well I think he really is a great
example of someone who was born on third
base who had tremendous advantages at
the beginning and it's not to take away
anything from what he's done over the
course of his life but what you are born
into a family like his that essentially
already has an existing very profitable
business not only the the money i mean
you know somewhere between 1 and 14
million dollars in loans that his father
gave them but also in relationships
political contacts length links to
lenders i just think we greatly
underestimate how much advantage gets
passed on when you're in a wealthy
family to the next generation and we've
had a few of these bored on third base
presidential candidates or presidents I
mean George W Bush Mitt Romney they were
all kind of big on talking about their
own business success without really kind
of fessing up to what I would say is the
huge advantages that they got
at the at the birth at Birth I'd be
curious to hear from you you know
currently if we compare Donald Trump to
Hillary Clinton Donald Trump is is
significantly wealthier than Hillary
Clinton but Hillary Clinton is also
significantly were wealthier than almost
everyone on this planet right so while
we're talking about two different
degrees of wealth they're both
incredibly wealthy individuals the
difference being as you're pointing out
Donald Trump born to a wealthy family
whereas Bill and Hillary Clinton have
accumulated wealth over the last 20
years at but mostly 20-30 years after
their entrance into public life in your
experience given the people you know and
your experience uh up being born into a
wealthy family is there any uh material
difference that the average person
should be aware of when we look and say
I yes I see two wealthy people one
wealthier than the other based on the
idea of one being born into it vs1
becoming wealthy as an adult well I
think the experience of say in a case of
Bill Clinton or Hillary Clinton growing
up in working-class families or even
poor families in the case of Bill
Clinton you know is a very very
different experience you have to sort of
overcome not only lack of money but
sometimes a lack of agency and other
challenges so it's very significant to
grow wealth or to become wealthy over
one's lifetime as opposed to just sort
of being born as I was in a Donald Trump
born into affluent families with these
you know with this incredible wind at
our back so I think first generation
entrepreneurs like my great-grandfather
you know but not me do have to make huge
sacrifices sometimes to get where they
are that said you're right all the
candidates and most of us in the top
fifth of the United States are in the
tippy-top II of income and wealth
holders from a global level in a
national level and we shouldn't lose
sight of the fact that we're really a
society now that's largely governed by
by people who are who are wealthy truck
you've talked about you've been an
advocate for the more extensive taxation
of
inheritances and there are a lot of sort
of shades of gray in that conversation
some saying all inheritances should be
taxed uh as ordinary income which would
be a significant increase to the way
inheritance is currently taxed others
saying hey it's someone in your family
worked hard enough to make the money you
shouldn't be punished because they want
to pass that money on to you and then
sort of in between would be the shades
of gray as to how much money do we want
to exempt from taxation based on a state
tax law give me your sense for your sort
of general principles and view on this
and then get a specific as you want in
terms of how and why you think it should
be managed in that way mm-hmm well you
know we're living in a time of extreme
inequality where huge concentrations of
wealth are accumulating at the top and
there are two good reasons why we should
tax accumulated wealth at a very very
high level one is just to put a brake on
that concentration of wealth if we don't
want to become a hereditary aristocracy
of wealth we have to do something to
limit it and the other is to recycle
that wealth you know my view is people
who have accumulated wealth at that
level didn't do it alone it's largely a
function of the society that we have
that creates a fertile ground and that
those folks should pay back the society
so that other people not born wealthy
and have the same opportunities that
they had so I'm an advocate of what I
would call a steeply progressive estate
tax you know once you know and actually
probably a wealth tax during life to a
modest wealth tax on wealth over put it
over a half a billion dollars of one
percent wealth tax and put it into
something that everyone can see like a
debt free education college fund or
something that helps early childhood
education something that's clearly
linked to opportunities for the next
generation some a program like that
would greatly reduce inequality but also
raise the floor and and create real
opportunities for everyone else what
about with individuals like for example
Bill Gates or maybe Warren Buffett is a
good recent example who's recently
designated a overwhelming portion of his
well
to go to the Gates Foundation a
charitable donation essentially rather
than creating his own foundation in the
Chuck Collins sort of a state tax plan
how would a very wealthy person who has
already said most of my wealth is going
to charity how would that impact your
sort of view on a state taxation and
wealth tax that's an excellent question
I would have I would advocate capping
the amount of wealth that can be given
to charity and where there's a deduction
and actually Bill Gates his dad Bill
Gates senior and I wrote a book together
about why we should keep the estate tax
and we traveled extensively and he quite
publicly said you know there's something
wrong with the possibility that my son
could give 82 billion dollars to charity
and never pay any taxes because taxes
pay for something quite different the
you know the charity charity work is
important and does innovate many things
are you know can be funded through
charity but charity does not build
public infrastructure it doesn't fund
the food stamps it doesn't keep our
national parks open so no one should be
able to completely opt out of paying
taxes especially if you have billions
and billions of dollars so I would say
there should be a lifetime cap again
maybe half a billion dollars above which
you can no longer you can give that
money away but you have to pay taxes on
that as a form of inheritance uh no one
should be able to opt out entirely just
because they're super wealthy I am
obviously uh my audience knows this
completely against the sort of standard
supply-side economic taxation ideas I
mean I recognize the straightforward
economics of if you lower the corporate
tax rate you're actually reducing the
incentive for a corporation to put that
money in play if you increase the
corporate tax rate you're actually
incentivizing businesses to hire more
and build etcetera I'm sort of thinking
along these incentive lines how would a
rich person be differently incentivize
or less incentivized to continue
whatever they're doing entrepreneurially
or otherwise if they know no matter how
well the
does I might not be able to pass all of
it on to my uh my family I might not be
able to get the tax benefit that I i
would expect or want donating the money
aren't you creating a disincentive for
some of the some of some people in our
society you know based on my
interviewing hundreds of entrepreneurs
people who are very very wealthy I think
that there's an it's there is an
incentive to get wealthy maybe for the
first five million or the first ten
million dollars but after a certain
point it is no longer really an
incentive it's not you know but you know
some people do like to keep score but
beyond that it's not an incentive and I
think more and more I'm encountering
people who are saying you know when you
reach a certain level of wealth you
actually do see this web of supports
that made it possible including not
everybody sees this web but a growing
number of people do that you know that
wealth is a function of this society and
an act of gratitude is not only to give
it back through charity but to pay it
back through taxes so that young people
the next generation can have the same
public infrastructure and opportunities
that the previous generation of wealth
creators did so you know I think I think
it's somewhat of a myth that you know
paying people a huge amounts of money is
an incentive it really after a certain
point it's no longer a driving incentive
for most about all the entrepreneurs
I've talked to let me remind you that
Chuck Collins's new book is born on
third base a one percenter makes the
case for tackling inequality bringing
wealth home and committing to the common
good uh the book is at extraordinary I
have read it and i encourage you to as
well Chuck great as always to talk to
you thanks David for the conversation